there is this notion
that asians are smarter than everybody
else but
we don't hear about the 15 hours of
studying per week which is twice as much
as everybody else so
you said the dual family husband and
wife you know mom and dad stay together
there
great what other values did you learn
from your dad i know you gave a couple
of them to us here
you know don't be lazy do your best
whatever you're doing give your best etc
etc
what standards and expectation was it to
be in the shoe family what were some of
the standards and expectations
yeah how do you yeah um well how do you
get to be the smartest in the class
right you you have to you know my dad
and my mom and for many chinese-american
korean-american vietnamese-american
families a lot of this is
a lot of this is very similar um you
you have a you have a certain role in
the family right your role
is you know and i talk about this in my
book an inconvenient minority your role
is you need to be academically excellent
you know you need to
to study hard and one of this i'll tell
you i'll give you
the example of math okay so you you're
given a problem set or a problem sheet
you know at an early age
and maybe you need to memorize a
multiplication table and you do problems
um in in our family you know if you
didn't do it right
um nobody's gonna punish you okay or
anything like that but you just gotta
keep doing it until you get it right you
know you got to keep doing until you get
it right you got to practice
you got to push forward asian americans
really believe that
math is just a sport of it's just a
sport of practice and practice and
continuing to do things
over and over again it's math is not
really that complicated you know it's
funny
that people like to say oh i'm not a
math person or anything like that
asian americans don't really believe
that you know you you can't
it doesn't matter if you're not a math
person you can do math and you can
achieve at a high level
my inherent interest wasn't even in math
my inherent interest was in writing i
was a writer
i was uniquely talented at writing and
yet i was a math major
in college because i was pushed from an
early age to
just work hard on problems think
creatively think abstractly
um and to most of all if i get stuck
to finish it to to get unstuck to do to
do the best i can
to get it done so if you like this sort
of short clip from an interview i did
click over here to watch the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel take care
everybody bye
you